hello and welcome back in this week you
learn about optimization algorithms that
will enable you to train in your
networks much faster you've heard me say
before that apply machine learning is a
highly empirical process is highly
intuitive process it which you just have
to train a lot of models to find one
that works really well so it really
helps to really train models quickly one
thing that makes it more difficult is
that deep learning which is the work
best in the regime of Big Data when
you're able to train your near network
on a huge data set and training on large
data sets is just slow so what you find
is that having fast optimization
algorithms having good optimization
algorithms can really speed up the
efficiency of you and your team so let's
get started by talking about mini-batch
gradient descent you've learned
previously the vectorization allows you
to efficiently compute on all M examples
that allows you to process your whole
training set without an explicit for
loop so that's why we would take our
training examples and stack them into
this huge matrix capital X so 6 1 X 2 X
3 you know and then um eventually it
goes up to X M they give M training
examples and similarly for y this is y 1
y 2 y 3 and so on up to Y M so the
dimension of X was n X by M and this is
1 by M vectorization allows you to
process our M examples quickly
relatively quickly if M is very large
then it can still be slow so for example
what if M was 5 million you know 50
million or even bigger with the
implementation of gradient sent on your
training set what you have to do is you
have to process your entire training set
before you take you know one little step
for gradient descent and then you have
to process your entire training set of
five million training examples again
before you take another little step of
gradient descent so it turns out that
you can get a faster algorithm if you
get straightened descent
start to make some progress even before
you finish processing your entire your
giant tree
in size of five million examples in
particular here's what you can do let's
say that you split up your training set
into smaller your little baby training
sets and these baby training sets are
called
mini batches and let's say each of your
baby training sets have just 1000
examples each so you take X 1 through X
1000 and you call that your first little
baby training session also called a mini
batch and then you take home the next
1000 examples X 1000 1 through X 2000
that's the next thousand examples and
call the next one and so on and I'm
going to introduce a new notation I'm
going to call this X superscript with
curly braces 1 and I want to call this X
superscript with curly braces too now if
you have five million training examples
total and each of these little mini
batches as a thousand examples that
means you have 5000 of these videos you
know 5000 times 1000 equals 5 million so
altogether you would have 5000 of these
um mini batches so the ends of X
superscript curly braces 5000 and then
similarly you do the same thing for y
you'd also split up your training data
for Y accordingly so you call that y1
and then this is y 1001 3y 2000 this
becomes called y2 and so on until you
have y 5000 so now we
- number T is going to be comprised of X
T and Y T and that is a thousand
training examples so the corresponding
input output pairs before moving on just
to make sure
notation is clear we have previously
used superscript round brackets I to
index on the training set so X is d I've
trained example we use superscript
square brackets L to index into the
different layers of a neural network so
VL comes from the Z values for the elf
layer of in your network and here we're
introducing the curly brackets T to
index into different mini batches so you
have X T Y T and to check your
understanding of these um or what's the
dimension right of XT and YT well X is
NX by M so if x1 is a thousand training
examples or the X values for a thousand
examples then this dimension should be
MX by 1,000 and x2 should also be an X
by 1000 and so on so all of these should
have to mention NX / 1000 and these
should have to mention 1 by 1000 right
the name of this algorithm - gradient
descent refers to the gradient descent
algorithm we've been talking about
previously where you process your entire
training set all at the same time and
the name comes from viewing that as
processing your entire batch of training
examples all at the same time I'm not
such a great name but that's just what
is called mini batch period descent in
contrast refers to the algorithm which
we'll talk about on the next slide and
which you process is single mini batch X
T YT at the same time rather than
processing your entire training set X Y
at the same time so let's see how many
batch gradient descent works to run
mini-batch gradient descent on your
training sets you would run for t equals
1 to 5000 because we had 5000 mini
batches of size 1,000 each and what
you're going to do inside the for loop
is basically implement one step of
gradient descent using X G comma Y T and
it's as if you had a training set of
size 1,000 examples and it was as if you
were to implement the algorithm you're
already familiar with but just on this
you know little training set size of M
equals 1000 rather than having explicit
for loop over all 1000 examples you
would use vectorization to process all
1,000 examples sort of all at the same
time so let's write this out first you
implement forward prop on the inputs so
just on XP and you do that by
implementing you know Z 1 equals W 1 now
previously we just have X there right
but now you're on process the entire
training set and you're just processing
the first mini batch so this becomes X
tea when you processing mini-batch tea
and then you would have a1 equals G 1 of
Z 1 District Capital Z since we're this
is actually a vectorized implementation
and so on until you end up with a l you
know as I guess GL of VL and then this
is your prediction and you notice that
here you should use a vectorized
implementation it's just that this
vectorized implementation processes
1,000 examples at a time rather than 5
million examples mixed you compute the
cost function J which I'm going to write
as 1 over 1000 since 301 thousands the
size of your little training set sum
from I equals 1 through L of really the
you know loss of Y hat I Y I and this
notation for clarity refers to examples
from the mini-batch XT YT and then if
you're using regularization you can also
have this regularization term just move
over to the denominator time sum over L
Frobenius norm the way measures a
squared so because this is really the
cost on just one rainy batch and then I
index this cost J with a superscript T
in curly braces so you notice that
everything we're doing is exactly the
same as when we were previously
implementing gradient descent except
that instead of doing it on X Y you're
not doing it on X T YT next you'd
implement back prop to compute
gradients with respect to really respect
to this JT so you're still using only X
T YT and then you update the weights you
know wre every WL gets updated as WL
minus alpha D WL and similarly for B and
so this is one pass through your
training set using mini-batch gradient
descent the code i've written down here
is also called doing one epoch of
training and epoch is a word that just
means a single pass through the training
set so whereas with batch gradient
descent a single pass through the
training set allows you to take only one
gradient descent step with really batch
gradient descent a single pass through
the training set that is one epoch
allows you to take 5000 gradient descent
steps now of course you want to take
multiple passes through the training
sets which you usually want to you might
want another for loop or another your
while loop out there so you keep taking
process through the training set until
hopefully you converge or it
approximately converged when you have a
lost training set meaning batch gradient
descent runs much faster than batch
gradient descent and it's pretty much
what everyone in deep learning will use
when you're training on a large dataset
in the next video let's delve deeper
into mini batch goodness and so you can
get a better understanding of what is
doing and why it works so well